あああーー
ん
失礼します
ああああああ
こんにちはー
ヴァンチュラ初めてです世の中には忙しい方
休む暇もない方たくさんいらっしゃいますが youtube クリエイターで特に
遺族 c 型
皆さんご存知でしょうか
そう
ヒカキンに追求インソンがとてもお忙しい方のお一人でございまして今回私始めた家を
買ってに羊として非課金様のサポートしにまいりました日間私が精一杯ご奉仕させて
いただきます
よろしくお願い致します
では勝手にまいりましょう
[音楽]
ん
ブーブー s あああああああっあっー日構えてまあまあよく使われてした
日足ください少量しかお願いしますそれじゃあこうですかいいえたら大変なんですよ
はいやはこれこアゾレスグランデこの子の持ち方からもしれなかったません
ああ
[音楽]
ブーバーちょっちょっ超姉ますからティ
入ってかしこまりましたねでもこの子の命を大事にたです
おっ
僕はいないこれ高いやつ
まあまあそうほどほどに誰か言っ
あえん
[音楽]
いよい感じでしょうかありがとうございました
ペンギンさんはこれぐらいであればもう朝飯前でございますね
もっときついやつかもっときついなんです
峻厳したい
失礼致します
おここが仕掛けに様ゲームビアですうんそうです
a
勝てないんだよ勝てないんだからゲーム得意だからあの勝ってほしい
ぶりなんですよね最近なかなかでみんなうまくて
畏れ治ってるけど全然いけますよ
うちの姉羊だといえばゲーム間くらいの話なんですがなるほどですね駄目だとか言って
の木日ですよそれはもう任せてください
鍵がそこ付く日ですこれをもういやほど付け方も叱る別れの日はこうですねまぁ
ブーブー言っニっまっっ
いろいろなんで
ながらならどこいくんだこれちょっと敵は以上ですありましたね
セイラさん
10秒じゃないなぁ
アホって言ってるなんてや合わせ a
改札混ぜますねえっましたケンプがちょっと雨ですね結構あいうえ
してくださいねくれなかったため匠加瀬政
のでよく見たらね
今夜のご協力しました
ああああああ
タイ語で妄想選べまでご主人と私のご要望で申し訳ないですから
はいどスジンさんを作れます
うぇーんですからちょっとぜひ宜しくお願いしますからさー
キミさんを頑張ってくださいはぶりはまあ同じ所はもうこれ一人倒せばまあ未さんに
わかってるいうことで私60要因でしたね
えっ1回この辺で銃を
阪神南から足てやばい育ってくれますねーやばいですね私も私も
ていません
ん
バッハ
特に旧90歳だ
恋にもありますございます次頑張りましょう黙ってくださいと路地も止まります
お待たせいたしましたじゅうすけ
僕の知己なぷれぷるーず10さんて橋者
優勝しなかったけど許してあげようありがとうございます首にしない
ゲームしてる場合じゃるんでねあさて追加も仕事に来ましたが
動画編集します
[音楽]
ここが滝沢の編集秒でございますねそうでチョコでゴリゴリに行ってます
君もできるようになったねーありがとうですわざわざ言葉で発しなくても伝わるんじゃ
ないかと
ございません幾何形状ものことはだいぶ上がってきておりましたん
小さはいマッサージしたことないんで神の幸からさ
ただ触ってるみたいな力イオ
はあああああ
はん
ちょっとまあは氏が自らのお寿司屋楼蘭
そんなことがあったこれは教えるという意味で凝ってる人間はわかるんですよ
たんで泡へ
これ凝ってるのはこれだろうし
[音楽]
何でも知れません松ジャパ
ここでこのそうそう親指力ですで決まります
大まかにいってらっしゃいは絶対兵種の様ですよね気もとか
健康へ行くもう集中できないから
練習してくださいかしこまりましたたかみなはこの時のためにはタクシーなので遠い
クレーターや戦で食べられました
是非皆さん見づらが非課金様の編集でございますこまけー
コレッティもチェックされてないんですかなまだされているまーす混ぜていきます
nest はちょっかいは好みが所持メロ
なあ
本当にご苦労様ですっな次行きましょうか
ああああああ
いやー
ちょっとシャキッとしたいけどかっこいいと生でも聞きたいん
恋ドラムはここで演奏していただいてパッ
私がそうしてしまった汁で大学1年生の時
4日間をの演出したことがございますやはりしつじたるものなんでもできなければご
主人様の指が食べない
叩かせていただきます
tar
ええええええええええええ
tee
[音楽]
各やーんどうですかもっ
インターン poooo
ダメやないかいと大沢ちょっとただけてうるさいって言ってる
[音楽]
できるねー
疲れ様です
只今ご主人さまが動画編集をがされておりますあまり邪魔にならないようにデフけども
私が出来る最大限のサポートさせて頂きたいと思っております
[音楽]
邪魔しちゃいけません
1年ぶりー
を社会だ
[音楽]
少しずん子があります
えええええっっ
いただきまーいただきましたいい
[音楽]
サッと味の方はどうです
愛機を買ったちおんなきゃいけないいけない
いいかいて構想していません
ああああああ
[音楽]
パップ組み勝っ大変だはいっ
とても編集に集中されている雇用制でございます
なかったです私そっと買い出しに行ってまいります
[音楽]
眠くなっちゃった
th
鉄鋼
[音楽]
ん
例えばもちょいます
検査もん
5 c のターン
寝ちゃってるよペットのほぼしないけれど
[音楽]
直角てるスペパイン
me
[音楽]
こそしてはっ
goo
妹ちゃん
yeah
ねぇ
経験 k 1 a 1 e たい
[拍手]
今だ
[音楽]
あううあおんぶおんぶおんぶおんぶおんぶおんぶおんぶおんぶおんぶおんぶおんぶおん
ぶおんぶわぁ
ok おっしゃー
goo
none
[音楽]
ぶーぶーっ
あああああ
戻ってきます
ちょっともう冷たいお水 page
汎用 macpac 米方へ yi ん
はい
あげ
[音楽]
今にゃーん
言った
これウリイ
[音楽]
[拍手]
そして今日
非課金様の一日が終わりました
[音楽]
また明日
今日もお勤めご苦労様でした
おやすみなさい
[音楽]
ああいうああああいいいいご主人様おはようございます
a
[音楽]
yeah ございますのすちー様ん
背面はい今日はに通されました
じゃあ日共やりたいのにも
はい
あぁーご主人様いやー五所神社だ
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
馴れ合え
ご主人様でしたーー
樋掛様ですか
うん
なんか小さくなって気がしますけど
大丈夫でしょうか
始めんと今日は卒が姫大外で発生いっぱいかしこまりました
ua
あへ行きましょう
私が甘やかし過ぎてしまったせいなのか
なぜか非課金様がお子様の姿になってしまった
小さくなった非課金様もとても素敵な形で一緒にフットサル場
走り回ったのだ
ああああ
ああああああ
失敗を指摘されない
[音楽]
いけないん
早いですねー
うーんまあでも俺3件に際だからさ
皆さんずね最後速さじゃない成果型なん
始め方ありがとう楽しかったよ
[音楽]
ていた
はい協議で訴追注意ヒカキンさんと僕が入っていたムーンスターのスーパースターなん
ですがバネの力でしっかり前に進める靴になっております
今年の初めにも僕コラボさせていただいたんですけども本当に走りやすくて軍勲前に
進む感じがします
限りさんどうでした
とても走りやすかったあーもうなによりで投与不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不
不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不のランダーも絶賛らしいのでぜひ
概要欄からチェックしてみてください
背面ハンバーグ食べた秘境刻むですから分かりました
これじゃあさんが望んでくださいカラー
[音楽]
ウォーカーし